okay let's talk about the EPA Donald
Trump is very very quickly moving us in
the direction of the world laughingstock
when it comes to climate change we
talked about Donald Trump
basically erasing the climate record and
policies of the Obama administration
from the White House website within
minutes of being inaugurated on January
20th Donald Trump has signed two
executive orders to try to push the
Keystone XL and Dakota access pipelines
Donald Trump has 50 mentions on his
Twitter account that climate change is a
hoax some of them specifically created
by the Chinese he has appointed or did
appoint Myron Ebel to guide the EPA
transition who is a total climate denier
and then now we know about the guy
appointed to run the EPA Scott Pruett
who has actually sued the EPA 14 times
he still hasn't been confirmed no vote
has been scheduled yet for Scott Pruett
and the new phase of this war against
science is that to EPA employees have
confirmed to Reuters that Donald Trump's
administration has instructed the EPA
which remember stands for Environmental
Protection to remove the climate change
page from their website trump
administration official asked for
comment about this they didn't they
didn't comment well I guess the upside
Pat is even if we destroy the planet in
the meantime we're gonna generate some
great investment returns for
shareholders of fossil fuel companies or
I guess the other hope here is that even
though the leadership in the EPA has
changed and people in charge now are
people like Scott Pruitt yeah the people
on the ground are mostly the same
well-educated scientists people who have
an understanding yeah so I think there
could be an imbalance there and that
could cause some unrest in the agency
yes and no because remember the Trump
transition team wanted to know who in
across all of these federal agencies
worked on climate change-related stuff
they were they were asking for names to
be named and there's also been a number
of different Trump staffers who said you
know it's perfectly logical to get rid
of staffers at the lower levels of these
agencies if they don't agree with your
philosophy so that could change and
they've been frantically trying to save
some of the data I'm trying to find a
silver lining here David there really
isn't
I mean there really isn't when Trump
said oh we're gonna be transparent I'm
gonna be draining the swamp and be super
transparent meanwhile a ton of climate
data was also removed from the EPA
website this is taxpayer funded research
that was available on the EPA website
it's gone both parties are the same
though remember Hillary and Trump are no
different if these first few days of
Trump have told us anything it's that
the entire Trump and Hillary would all
effectively be the same narrative is
totally and completely bogus is there a
single Democrat a single Democrat who
would order climate science data removed
from the agency charged with
environmental protection this tells us
how extreme Donald Trump is compared to
everybody else
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salesperson
sort of hovers over me and I like more
than 30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at-home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker comm slash
TDP s it costs nothing